[Musique]
merci Guillaume Gontard de nous
accompagné pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes élu dzer membre de
la commission des affaires étrangères et
président du groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoire on a évidemment
beaucoup de sujets à avoir avec vous on
va parler dans quelques instants de
l'audition de Catherine Colona mais
d'abord ce matin ont lieu les obsèques
de Dominique Bernard ce professeur tué
par une attaque islamique à haras cétait
vendredi dernier Gabriel Atal hier a
annoncé qu'au moins 300 57 perturbations
et contestations ont eu lieu pendant
l'hommage à ce professeur est-ce que
vous êtes inquiet aujourd'hui pour la
laïcité à l'école bah d'abord avoir une
pensée pour pour la famille les proches
les collègues de Dominique Bernard une
pensée également pour Samuel paatti
parce que c'est vrai que ce qui se passe
dans notre pays est particulièrement
grave inquiétant c'est ce sont c'est
encore un professeur qui se qui meurt
pendant pendant ses fonctions c'est
l'école le lieu d'émancipation qui est
qui est àataquer c'est le cœur de notre
de notre République donc oui évidemment
que ça doit nous interroger et je pense
qu'il faut arriver à à prendre
suffisamment de de hauteur pour apporter
les bonnes les bonnes réponses
évidemment je pense que on doit arriver
à le faire dans l'unité en tout cas on a
cette responsabilité là tous mais c'est
quoi les bonnes réponses pour vous sur
cette question bah il me semble que pour
moi les bonnes réponses et j'ai j'ai
participé à plusieurs manifestations
plusieurs cérémonie ces derniers temps
ce que j'ai entendu de la part de la
part des professeurs de la part du corps
enseignant c'est quand même de dire que
depuis la mort de Samuel Patti où on
avait promis on avait réfléchi à
beaucoup de choses que pas grand-chose
justement avait avancé et que depuis 3
ans ma ma collègue Monique dearco avait
d'ailleurs posé une question il y a il y
a 3 ans en disant qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que nous allons mettre en
place on s'aperçoit aujourd'hui qu'on
est à peu près dans la même dans la même
situation et ce qu'on constate aussi et
la demande de de ses professeurs bah
c'est la demande d'humain de présence
humaine euh je pense qu'on souffre
beaucoup dans notre pays à tous les
stades de cette présence humaine de cet
accompagnement que ça soit en terme de
de professeur que ça soit en terme
d'encadrement dans les dans les collèges
et les lycées et les écoles à tous les
niveaux de notre société on manque
cruellement de cette de cette présence
humaine et hélas ce que je vois et ce
que je vois dans les différentes
orientations que ça soit en nombre de
professeurs on annonce encore une baisse
du nombre du nombre de professeurs euh
sur la programmation des des finances
publiques qui a été voté au Sénat hier
ou avant-ti euh on est encore sur des
projections de 120000 de demandé par les
républicains de 120000 fonctionnaires en
moins je pense que ce n'est pas
raisonnable dans dans aujourd'hui dans
la société dans laquelle nous vivons au
contraire parce que 120000
fonctionnaires en moins ce sont des
femmes ce sont des hommes qui font vivre
justement notre société notre démocratie
notre République et nous en avons
terriblement besoin la saant a été mise
en examen il a fait référence à l'état
islamique Gérald haranin veut intégrer
au projet de loi immigration une
disposition permettant de retirer son
titre de séjour à un étranger qui adhère
à une idéologie djihadiste est-ce que
vous soutiendrez cette
mesure en tout cas il faut que toutes
les mesures qui soient prises euh soi
euh en concordance avec avec l'État de
droit et qu'on ne peut pas prendre des
des mesures d'exception sur mesure
d'exception donc il faut eu et celle-là
pour vous elle est c'est pas une bonne
mesure ben en fait soit euh la personne
en question tombe sous le coup de la loi
et donc là effectivement il y a une une
procédure qui est mise en place mais là
il veut changer la loi pour qu'elle
tombe sous le lo on peut êre oui mais on
peut pas être entre deux quoi c'està
dire on au cas par cas euh il y a il y a
certainement je ve dire à partir du
moment où une personne effectivement
déclare directement euh faire partie
d'une organisation terroriste ou faire
l'apologie du terrorisme il me semble
que c'est déjà prévu par la loi euh donc
c'est ça que je ne comprends pas tout à
fait dans ce que veut faire
Gérald daranin moi il me semble qu'il
faut qu'on reste dans cette question de
l'État de droit et fasse qu'est-ce que
veulent les
terroristes quand il s'attaquent à notre
à notre pays en fait il s'attaquent à la
démocratie il s'attaque à nos valeurs et
la meilleure réponse c'est justement de
de défendre de défendre nos valeurs de
défendre notre cadre démocratique de
rester dans l'État de droit parce que
c'est vrai qu'on pouvit on pourrait
avoir à chaque fois cette tentation de
se dire face à la peur qui est légitime
face à ce qui se passe de se dire qu'on
pourrait faire des exceptions qu'on
pourrait sortir notre État de droit je
pense que ça serait une grave erreur et
surtout c'est exactement vous il faut
pas faciliter l'expulsion notamment de
radicaliser dangereuse que permettrait
ce projet de loi immigration mais ça
dépend ce qu'on ce qu'on met
derrière quelqu'un qui est radicalisé
évidemment qu'il faut mais encore une
fois il faut l'accompagner et on voit
que l'expulser n'est pas forcément
suffisant on voit de toute façon que
souvent ils reviennent quand on voit les
les actes qui ont pu être re qu'on Puut
être commis la vraie question encore une
fois c'est toute toute la l'attention
qui va être portée et c'est-à-dire
d'avoir une une véritable vision et vrai
suivi de ces personnesl encore encore
une fois ça demande de la PR on suivi
mais qu'on peut pas les expulser
derrière mais l'expion une chose ce que
je veux dire non mais ce que je veux
dire c'est une expion il faut que les
choses soit très clair et on peut pas se
dire voilà sur quel critère on se
radicalité l'assant il était suivi par
les renseignements généraux bah on voit
qu'il était suivi mais on voit qu'en
tout cas il était pas suffisamment suivi
et puis tout ça c'est très difficile on
voit bien justement que quand il y a ce
suivi quelqu'un qui va passer à l'acte
c'est très complexe mais ce que je
constate aussi c'est que cette
personne-là était en lien avec son père
qui avait été expulsé qui était à
l'extérieur du territoire et on voit
bien que c'est comme ça d'ailleurs que
les choses se sont mises en place donc
le problème est beaucoup plus complexe
en tout cas moi je me méfie beaucoup des
des mesures comme ça qui seraient pris à
la vite encore une fois je pense qu'on a
a besoin d'unité on a besoin de prendre
de la de la de la hauteur
euh changer des ch on a compris vous
voez pas Tex bah le le texte le texte
sur l'immigration tel qu'il est tel
qu'il est fait évidemment qu'on ne qu'on
ne le votera pas on apportera évidemment
des propositions comme on le fait
toujours on apportera notre ligne parce
qu'on ne dit pas que tout va bien
évidemment il y a des choses à changer
il y a des choses à améliorer mais dans
dans l'état on ne votera pas Tex et
surtout on ne votera pas des mesures
comme ça qui sont prises euh à la fois
sur le coup de l'émotion qui sont qui
sont
particulièrementquel il faut faire très
attention on va parler de la situation
au ProcheOrient vous avez auditionné
hier la ministre des Affaires étrangères
Catherine Colona on va voir les temps
forts de cette audition avec Mathias
[Musique]
Arz bonjour Mathias bonjour bonjour
guillumeard bonjour Alors Mathias hier
la ministre des Affaires étrangères
Catherine colonne a été entendue par la
commission des affaires Affaires
étrangères à la base c'était sur le
budget 2024 mais évidemment il a été
question de l'actualité absolument vu le
contexte les sénateurs lui ont quand
même parlé de la situation au
Moyen-Orient en ouverture de son
audition la ministre des Affaires
étrangères a donc fait un point sur le
regain de tension entre Israël et la
Palestine et si évidemment Catherine
Colona s'est bien gardé d'une quelconque
analyse elle a rappelé les priorités de
la France pour ce qui concerne l'urgence
de demander l'accès humanitaire à la
bande de Gaza des bienens de première
nécessité des médicaments qui sont
indispensables aux populations réfugié
dans le sud en particulier de demander
la protection des civils et de demander
d'une façon générale le respect du droit
international par
Israël dans l'exercice de son droit à se
défendre Guillaume Gontard vous étiez
présent lors de cette audition hier ce
corridor humanitaire il tarde à arrivé
est-ce que la France met selon vous tous
ces moyens tous les moyens en neufs pour
accélérer sa mise en place bah en tout
cas ce que j'ai constaté c'est que la
France avait tardé en tout cas pour
avoir une parole claire lisible sur ce
qui se passe et les événements
dramatiques sur le conflit
israëlo-palestinien évidemment
rappeler le cette attaque
terrible du du du du Hamas et cette
attaque cette attaque terroriste
qui évidemment je dire a attaqué dans
son cœur le peuple le peuple israélien
qui a un droit de défense évident et qui
a un droit à la sécurité dans son dans
son pays c'est
incontestable et rien ne pourra
justifier ne justifiera en tout cas
cette attaque du
Hamas et puis ensuite il y a ce qui se
passe c'est-à-dire la réponse justement
qui est apportée par par Israël et je
pense que la parole de la France doit
être très claire c'est-à-dire un le
respect du droit international
la ministre vient de de le rappeler mais
on a un petit peu tardé en tout cas
Emmanuel Macron ne l'a pas tout de suite
dit a laissé quelques jours avant de
rappeler quand même cette évidence le
respect du droit du droit international
dans ce droit aussi à se défendre
évidemment ça c'est une première chose
l'ouverture d'un corridor sanitaire ça
me paraît une évidence et effectivement
il faut le demander et en urgence total
on a effectivement des des des
médicaments des des des vivres et cetera
qui attendre devant la frontière
égyptienne je pense qu'il faut mettre en
œuvre en tout cas que ces vives puissent
arriver on est quand même mais là hier
Israël a dit que que l'aide humitaire
arriverait dans la bande de Gaza via
l'Égypte ça vous rassure bah ça me
rassure en tout cas je faut fa faut voir
en tout cas pour l'instant elle n'y est
pas on est quand même dans une dans une
je suis allé à à Gaza il y a un peu plus
d'un plus d'un an c'est quand même une
prison à à ciel ouvert c'est plus de 2
millions de personnes la moitié
d'enfants la zone la plus dense au monde
et donc on est dans une situation
terrible une situation terrible et qu'on
ne peut pas accepter encore une fois je
pense qu'il y a ce corridor sa et puis
qu'il faut appeler évidemment à in
cesser le feu et ce que je constate
c'est que la France la France a toujours
eu une parole singulière sur son conflit
Israël palestinien mais une parole forte
une parole qui a toujours été entendue
qui a parfois été justement silencieuse
et ça on pourrait se poser aussi des
questions sur ce qui s'est passé avant
mais la France doit reprendre cette
parole là et doit être évidemment
beaucoup plus ferme sur le
respect le respect du droit
international mais aussi de trouver les
conditions d'incesser le feu ça me
paraît indispensable on a vu ce qui
s'est passé le nombre de morts qui n'est
plus possible de dire à des populations
de se déplacer dans une zone très petite
et aussi dense ce n'est pas possible et
là on est en train de bombarder d'une
manière ou d'une autre des populations
civiles des enfants on voit qu'on a
dépassé qu'on est presque à 1000 enfants
qui ont été tués sur cette bande de Gaza
ce n'est plus ce n'est plus acceptable
alors il y a une résolution brésilienne
qui avait été proposée s soutenue par
par la
France c'était une bonne chose on peut
se poser la question quand on lit ce
qu'il y a dans cette résolution pourquoi
les États-Unis notamment se sont opposés
à cette résolution on va en parler mais
d'AB parce qu'il en a été question hier
lors de votre audition mais d'abord
Mathias Catherine Colona également
prévenu d'un risque d'escalade dans la
région oui c'est le deè axe des efforts
diplomatiques français dans la région un
appel à la responsabilité pour éviter
justement l'embrasement on
l'écoute appelle à la responsabilité
pour éviter l'escalade et éviter un
embrasement régional qui pourrait
atteindre peut-être plusieurs pays
ententer peut-être d'autres et ne
laisserait sans doute pas nos propres
territoires totalement à l'écart de
tension que l'on voit déjà à l'œuvre
Catherine Colona a également parlé de la
nécessité de redonner un horizon de paix
aux habitants de la région avec cette
position historque historique de la
France celle de la d'une solution à deux
états qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
aujourd'hui cette position historique
qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour se diriger
vers elle qu'est-ce que fait la France
en tout cas cette cette position de deux
états
euh est à la fois indispensable en tout
cas pour réamorcer en tout cas des des
des discussions pour aller vers un
chemin de un chemin de paix après elle
est aussi c'est c'est c'est la soltion
puisquil a pas il y en a pas d'autres et
donc je pense qu'il faut travaille sur
cette sur cette question là mais ça veut
dire que de de porter cette question de
deux états ça veut dire aussi encore une
fois respect du droit international
arrêt des colonisations et retour en
tout cas des des colons sur les
territoires sur les territoire occupé et
donc ça c'est indispensable si l'on veut
avancer justement sur sur ces sur ces
discussions et aller vers vers vers deux
États qui puivent vivre en paix moi ce
que je constate hein que ça soit les
Palestiniens que ça soit les Israéliens
en grande
majorité ces peuples veuvent vivre en
paix et donc on a cette responsabilité
cette responsabilité internationale de
faire en sorte qu'on arrive à sortir 75
ans de conflit de guerre de morts dans
des des deux parties ce n'est plus ce
n'est plus possible et donc je dirais
derrière ce massacre derrière tout ce
qui s'est passé bah la la la petite
pleur d'espoir elle est là reprend des
discussion arriver à remettre justement
un petit peu de lien alors la question
se pose aussi c'est discuter avec qui
euh est-ce que l'on peut discuter avec
le Hamas je ne pense pas par contre ça
pose la question justement de l'Autorité
palestinienne de quelle Autorité
palestinienne et ça ça a été aussi un
manquement on a en Palestine depuis plus
de 15 ans toute une génération qui n'a
pas voté qui ne s'est pas exprimé sur
l'avenir de son pays je pense qu'il y a
une responsabilité encore une fois de la
France de l'Europe de la communauté
internationale de ne pas avoir réussi
justement à permettre en tout cas
l'organisation d'élections qui aurait au
moins per permis d'avoir un portage
politique un avenir politique pour pour
les Palestiniens donc c'est peut-être
aussi des choses sur lequelles il faut
qu'on travaille pour avoir un vrai
dialogue et pour avoir un vrai
interlocuteur et Mathias il y a aussi eu
un petit quque pendant cette audition
absolument la ministre a annoncé à 16h38
précise je vous donne l'heure vous allez
voir pourquoi elle a annoncé qu'une
résolution brésilienne venait d'être
adoptée par le Conseil de sécurité de
l'ONU condamnant clairement le Hamas et
ses actions terroristes appelant à la
désescalade et rappelant les principes
fondamentaux du droit humanitaire
problème à 16h25 soit 13 minutes plusut
tôt nous recevions une alerte de l'AFP
spécifiant que cette même résolution
venait d'être rejeté Orian suite au
vetau des États-Unis vous l'évoquz
Guillaume Gontard petite précision ce
veto a été apposé car le texte ne
mentionnait pas et bien le droit
d'Israël à se défendre la ministre a
ensuite expliqué au cours de l'audition
elle a dit que et bien elle parlait de
l'état des négociation ainsi que du vote
favorable de la France bref est-ce que
vous vous vous regrettez que cette
résolution n'est pas été adopté surtout
pour ces raisons-là bah oui parce qu'on
sait très bien qu'une résolution c'est
le fruit de de nombreuses discussion
d'échange et je pense que s'il y avait
eu cet élément- là à à ajouter
évidemment que le droit d'Israël à se
défendre c'est un c'est un droit
évident d'assurer sa sa sécurité mais
c'est vrai que quand on regarde ce qui
est écrit dans cette résolution c'est
d'abord une
condamnation ferme directe des attaques
du du du Hamas des attaques terroriste
c'est un soutien évidemment au peuple au
peuple israélien et puis ce sont
justement des perspectives et puis
surtout un un respect du droit
international et la mise en place d'un
cordon d'un cordon sanitaire sur la
bande sur la bande de Gaza donc c'est
vrai que ça peut interroger notamment de
la part des États-Unis de s'être opposé
à cette résolution parce que je pense
que c'est à travers des des des des des
propositions de ce type là qu'on pourra
avancer et qu'on pourra sortir de cette
confrontation tion pour moi une guerre
contre la terreur ne mènera ne mènera à
rien on on on l'a déjà vu on risque
effectivement on est sur une sur une
pudrière on risque un embrasement total
de la région et que notre responsabilité
la responsabilité internationale au
contraire c'est de trouver des solutions
des solutions de paix alors c'est jamais
c'est facile à dire c'est jamais facile
à mettre à mettre en place mais toutes
ces éléments qui peuvent permettre
justement de retrouver un chemin de de
la paix devrait être pris et c'est vrai
que je ne comprends pas évidemment la la
position américaine il y a un débat qui
aura lieu mardi prochain au Sénat
justement sur la situation Proche-Orient
à la demande du gouvernement certains
sénateurs notamment de la droite et du
centre voulent que soit examiné une
proposition de résolution sur la
condamnation des crimes du Hamas et sur
le soutien indéfectible au peuple
israélien ce qui aurait permis un vote
alors que là mardi ce sera une
discussion sans vote est-ce que vous le
regrettez que cette proposition de
résolution na pas été mis à l'ordre du
jour par le gouvernement ben cette cette
résolution je pense que soit on on on
arrive suffisamment à prendre de la
hauteur et avoir une responsabilité
politique et à travailler sur une
résolution on va dire transpartisane en
tout cas qui soit acceptable par tout le
monde ce qui n'était pas le cas qui loin
loin de loin de là et puis surtout ça
veut dire qu'on ne peut pas occulter
évidemment évidemment la condamnation je
l'ai je l'ai dit et je le redis de de de
l'attaque du Hamas le la protection
d'Israël le droit à la sécurité évid
qu'il faut que ça soit présent dans
cette résolution mais on peut pas non
plus occulter la question de ce qui se
passe à Gaza du peuple palestinien des
solutions de sortie en fait de ce de ce
conflit effectivement tout cette cette
partie là manquait aussi dans ce dans ce
texte et je trouve du coup beaucoup plus
sage la position du du gouvernement que
je salue d'ailleurs d'avoir plutôt
organiser un un débat 50-1 alors
évidemment il n'y aura pas de vote mais
à la rigur je me dis euh je suis pas sûr
certain qu'un vote aurait changé quelque
chose euh je veux dire je pense qu'on
est euh voilà on on peut que chacun que
chaque groupe politique puisse
s'exprimer sur cette situation très
grave moi ça me paraît sain ça me paraît
aussi permettre justement de de
retrouver cette cette unitél plutôt
qu'essayer de faire des coups politique
on va parler des conséquences politiques
merci Mathias à tout à l'heure à tout à
l'heure des conséquences politiques à
gauche et notamment sur l'ANUP puisque
les propos de la direction de la France
insoumise notamment de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon de matine Panau de Daniel
auonau fracture euh laanup est-ce qu'il
faut que les les qui ont refusé je
précise hein de qualifier le Hamas
d'organisation terroriste Daniel obono
dit même que c'est un mouvement de
résistance est-ce qu'il faut que les
écologistes suspendent leur relation
avec la France insoumise bah d'abord
effectivement sur les sur la position de
la France insoumise sur cette question
d'une partie de la France insoumise
parce que ce n'est pas tous euh mais le
fait de ne pas arriver à qualifier ces
actes de terroriste c'est totalement
inconcevable donc euh ça je les laisse à
leur à leurs explications en tout cas
pour pour moi pour nous c'est totalement
inconcevable dès le premier jour
évidemment et les premières heures nous
avons condamné ces ces actes ces actes
terroristes sur la question de la de la
nupes pour moi le le l'union de la
gauche des écologistes elle est
indispensable on n jamais gagné aucune
aucune élection sans être uni on partage
énormément de de choses chacun avec et
chacune avec nos nos sensibilité donc
pour moi mais quelle union Guillaume
Ganta est-ce qu'il faut suspendre les
relations avec la
France question c'est pas l'Union c'est
pas la nupes c'est ce qu'on a fait de la
nupes la nupes c'était un accord pour
une élection
législative qui du coup a a plutôt servi
puisque ça a permis d'avoir un certain
nombre un certain nombre de députés ça a
permis de partager aussi et de mettre
sur la table un certain nombre de
divergences déjà puisqu'on était
conscient des divergences que l'on
pouvait que l'on pouvait avoir mais vous
en parlez au passé elle est morte
aujourd'hui non parce que pour moi il a
manqué l'étape d'après il a manqué
c'està dire que oui c'était un accord
législatif on aurait dû le poursuivre on
aurait dû le travailler pour mieux
organiser les formes de fonctionnement
qu'on peut avoir un petit peu comme dans
une famille oui a des entités
différentes le respect de ces entités
différentes des paroles de de chacun et
peut-être de la méthode et de
l'organisation et il a manqué peut-être
cette étape là et on s'en aperçoit
aujourd'hui c'est pas possible que quand
la France insoumise s'exprime on ait
l'impression que ça soit la parole de
l'anupes ça c'est une vraie
problématique c'est pas possible par
exemple pour les sénatoriales que une
entité moi j'avais une liste de
rassemblement où j'avais quatre
organisations avec moi issu de de la
nupes et que la LFI utilise laanupè je
pense qu'il faut un respect entre nous
tous mais est-ce qu'aujourd'hui il faut
suspendre les relations c'est ce que
demande diannick jado qui est sénateur
de votre groupe il dit il faut suspendre
les relations tant qu'il y a pas de
clarification sur les valeurs est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous dites il faut
suspendre les rel moi je suis toujours
pour le dialogue on on ne pour ne pourra
pas travailler chacun de notre côté ce
n'est pas possible la gauche les éces
ont toujours travaillé ensemble
par contre ce qu'il faut peut-être
suspendre c'est la méthode actuelle et
c'est ça et moi j'appelle plutôt à une
véritable discussion entre toutes les
entités
a pour reconstruire les bases alors
après c'est un autre problème il y a il
y a la problématique du du personnage
Jean-Luc Mélenchon je pense que oui
c'est une vraie problématique et je
pense qu'à un moment donné il faut qu'on
refixe les lignes effectivement on a des
divergences fortes je pense qu'il faut
qu'on refixe les lignes qu'il faut qu'on
refixe les cadres et qu'on voit
effectivement si la France insoumise
peut se retrouver dans ce dans ce
cadre-là je pense qu'il y a un certain
nombre de de personnes de la France
insoumise on l'a vu avec euh François
Ruffin avec Clémentine tin qui se sont
démarqués euh de des des des positions
de de Jean-Luc de Jean-Luc Mélanchon
donc je pense qu'on a un un un périmètre
en tout cas à recréer et retrouver aussi
des conditions de travailler ensemble
moi ça ne me choque pas que
chaqueorganisation et sa responsabilité
quand il euh porte porte un projet quand
il porte une idée mais il ne faut pas
que ça entache l'autre par contre il y a
des choses qu'on peut porter ensemble et
donc c'est comme ça il faut revenir à
une nouvelle méthode on va terminer par
l'actualité dans nos régions on va aller
dans le Var retrouver guilem ricavi
bonjour guilem merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous directeur éditorial de Var
Matin on va parler d'un tout autre sujet
avec vous et c'est un sujet qui
évidemment va intéresser Guillaume
Gonard c'est l'arrêt par Air-France de
plusieurs lignes depuis Orly dont la
ligne or Nice et Orly Marseille
évidemment on imagine que ça fait pas
que des heureux
oui effectivement he l'annonce hier de
l'arrêt de ces lignes à l'horizon 2026
autant dire dans un petit peu moins de 3
ans a suscité de très nombreuses
réactions ici dans le sud à commencé par
les réactions des chefs d'entreprisees
qui sont souvent très utilisateurs de
cette liaison entre le territoire et la
capitale ils l'utilisent très
régulièrement et ils sont donc inquiet
de cet arrêt et puis autre réaction
c'est celle des élus des élus locaux à
l'image d'éic cotti a dans les alpes
maritimes ou de Martine vassal dans les
bouche du rô qui eux aussi sont très
mécontents parce qu'il voient dans
l'arrêt de ces lignes en quelque sorte
de service public et
bien un signe de désintérêt pour leur
territoire il demande à ce que la copie
soit revue alors d'autres
opérateurs réalisent ces liaisons là
mais selon eux le rythme assuré par Air
France permettait des déplacements assez
faciles alors il y a bien sûr
l'alternative du train 3h30 pour faire
Paris Marseille c'est raisonnable en
revanche dès lors qu'il s'agit d'aller à
Nice et tant que la ligne nouvelle n'est
pas créée il faut quasiment compter 6h
ce qui rend très difficile un simple
aller-retour dans la journée vous avez
une question
guilem oui alors j'imagine que vous êtes
satisfait en tant que militant
écologiste de ce recul de l'avion hein
qui est un moyen de transport qui aimait
beaucoup de CO2 en même temps comment on
fait pour concilier cet impératif
écologique et cette nécessité économique
parce qu'on pense aux chefs
d'entreprises ici du sud de la France
qui ont besoin de se rendre euh à Paris
régulièrement est-ce que l'équation euh
a une solution ou est-ce qu'elle est
totalement insoluble selon vous B en
fait euh pourquoi on arrête cette ligne
c'est pas parce que les écologistes ont
gagné ou parce que voilà c'est pour des
raisons économiques c'est un choix d'Air
France hein de d'arrêter d'arrêter cette
ligne donc ça ça doit nous interroger
effectivement sur le modèle aérien euh à
l'intérieur d'un pays sur des distances
qui sont qui sont assez courtes et
encore une fois euh faire de la
politique c'est prévoir et cette
situation là je pense qu'on aurait
effectivement pu la prévoir quand on
avait déjà discuté dans la loi climat
sur les alternatives à des lignes à des
lignes aériennes avec des alternatives
au train hein d'ailleurs il y a des
dispositions quand on y alnative de
moins de 2h et3i dans la dans la loi là
c'est pas le cas effectivement moi je
suis déjà allé à Nice effectivement
d'autres enfin le le la possibilité en
tout cas reste reste l'avion dans des
temps plutôt plutôt court et qu'il n'y a
pas d'alternative on va dire fiable en
tout cas par le par le train et donc
c'est vraiment cette question là c'est
quelle priorité on donne à notre pays en
terme d'aménagement du territoire en en
terme de liaison ferroviaire TGV quand
il y en a un besoin et là pour le coup
il y avait besoin de de prolonger al il
y a un projet qui est qui est en cours
et donc il va falloir ENF cette
cohérence qu'il faut avoir sur
l'ensemble de l'aménagement du du du
territoire mais encore une fois prévoir
merci et merci guilem Guem regarde la
Une de Var Matin recherche nous
désespérément le Var fait partie des
pires départements en matière d'accueil
des enfants de 0 à 3 ans merci guilem
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin merci
beaucoup Guillaume Gontard à très vite
évidemment